Britain has voted to leave the EU with
the UK referendum finally over here are
some of the winners of brexit the former
Mayor of London made himself the face of
the leave campaign it was a major
political gamble for the man who some
political analysts have tipped as the
next prime minister investors craving
safe havens had caused gold to jump up
more than 20% in the lead-up to the
referendum with more market volatility
on the way it should continue to rise
with Britain voting to leave the EU
London's status as Europe's undisputed
financial capital is under threat Dublin
and Amsterdam are just a couple of the
cities vying for the crown and here are
the losers the former prime minister
brought this on himself calling an EU
referendum to shore up his political
base he resigned shortly after the
result and it's likely that his legacy
will forever be defined by this vote
after a rough start to 2016 the pound is
at its lowest in almost 30 years it is
the worst performing major currency
tracked by bloomberg so far this year
and of course there'll be no shortage of
trouble for the big banks shares are
likely to plummet and you can expect
years of regulatory uncertainty